la bandera del organismo Internacional
de la energía atómica izada frente a
esta central en el suroeste de Ucrania
un momento simbólico que marca el inicio
de una Estancia permanente de los
expertos de la agencia en el país
vamos a dejar un grupo de expertos que
se quedarán acá permanentemente y lo
mismo ocurrirá en todas las demás
plantas donde trabajaremos codo con codo
con nuestros anfitriones ucranianos nos
aseguraremos de que estas instalaciones
tan importantes para el país
especialmente en estos tiempos difíciles
sigan funcionando con normalidad y sin
problemas
[Música]
en concreto se enviarán expertos en
grupos de dos a todas estas centrales
nucleares ucranianas a Ucrania del sur
arritminewski pero también a chernóbil
la única que no funciona desde la
catástrofe de 1986 sus miembros ya están
instalados en saporilla la mayor central
eléctrica del país controlada por tropas
rusas esta semana ha llegado un nuevo
equipo de tres personas para sustituir
al anterior una misión a que las
autoridades ucranianas siguen de
cercaña
volveremos a la central nuclear de
saporilla eso lo cuestión de tiempo pero
la cuestión clave y muy importante es el
estado en el que volveremos a nuestra
planta y aquí la misión del Hoya es muy
importante estudiar a lo que está
ocurriendo allí Qué medidas se están
tomando implementando allí
la situación sigue siendo precaria por
ella donde los seis reactores están sin
funcionamiento el suministro eléctrico
es ágil la última línea eléctrica se
desconectó varias veces la semana pasada
sin embargo es esencial garantizar la
seguridad del